[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN AHARON: I'm excited
to be here at Google Cloud
Next talking to
you about a topic
that I'm very excited
about-- speech recognition.
I hope you're having a great
time here at Google Cloud Next.
So why do we even have
speech recognition
at Google Cloud Platform?
So we started developing
speech recognition at Google
more than a decade ago--
I think even more
than 15 years ago.
And we did it for our
internal uses, for Web Search,
and later for our
other apps, because we
figured that voice will be used
very prominently in our apps.
But we never intended to
offer it to third parties
as a commercial service
and that changed last year.
And the reason why
that changed was we
went through a big revolution
at Google with machine learning.
I'm sure you've
heard a lot about it
in our keynotes this
year and last year.
And we really wanted to help
other companies take advantage
of machine learning and benefit
the same way that we did,
and we're doing that
in two different ways.
One way is we're
helping companies
build their own custom
machine learning models.
And anyone can use TensorFlow.
It's open source.
Just download it for free and
start using it right away.
Or we started offering
in beta in September,
and yesterday we announced
general availability
for Cloud Machine
Learning Engine, which
lets anyone use machine
learning on the cloud
to develop their own models.
So that's very
exciting, and we think
over time that's going to enable
a lot of new opportunities,
different use cases
for businesses.
But the reality is
that most businesses
don't have the expertise,
or the resources,
or the data that is needed
to develop their own custom
models.
And in our aspiration
to still enable
people to take advantage
of machine learning,
we also offer what we call
our machine learning APIs--
so ready-to-use models that
anyone can just use as an API,
as a service, that we've
already pre-trained.
And in that set we have
Cloud Vision, Cloud Speech,
Cloud Jobs, Cloud Translation,
Natural Language API.
And then yesterday,
we added one more
to this list, which is our
new Video Intelligence API.
So that's how speech sort
of fits into the picture.
We're very, very
excited about Speech.
It's currently in beta.
It's about to go
GA very, very soon.
So what is so
exciting about Speech?
Speech recognition--
people have been doing it
for a very long period of
time, but it's actually
in an inflection
point right now.
So other analysts have said
it's now the biggest revolution
in human computer interactions
since the iPhone introduced
Touch, so 10 years ago.
And it's dramatically
changing the way
applications are being
developed and will
be developed in the future.
Voice is faster, easier,
more convenient in many ways
than typing or
navigating through menus.
And so we're seeing,
just in the last year,
an explosion of voice apps.
But in the future, we're
going to see even more of it.
Today, more than 20% of
our Android app searches
are already voice, and we're
very excited about that.
We want to make it
as easy as possible
to use all of our services,
as we're sure all app
developers are out there.
So in terms of the
broader landscape
for speech recognition,
what is it good for?
We kind of see it
in two broad themes.
One is around
human-computer interaction,
what we just talked about.
So that is things like
voice search, voice actions,
messaging, dictation.
This is fuelling
different services
like mobile apps, web
apps, connected devices,
and to a lesser extent
also phone-directed apps,
and basically enabling
a new way for humans
to interact with systems.
The other big domain
is speech analytics,
and this is fairly new.
We're just starting to see
this come out in a big way
now, because the technology
is starting to be big enough.
And that could be call-center
analytics, video analytics,
messaging, meeting analytics--
basically taking speech that is
already happening in our world
today and generating
new insights from it.
So I'm going to show you later
a bunch of different demos
more centered around
the domain on the left,
on human-computer interaction.
And I'm going to invite
our guest speaker, Gary,
who's going to show you
how they implemented a very
interesting use case
on the right-hand side,
on call-center analytics.
So yeah, it's going
to be a fun session.
We're also going to do a
kind of a crazy code lab.
I'm going to try and write an
app in less than 10 minutes
that will do speech
recognition, sentiment
analysis, and translation
using Google's APIs.
So hopefully it will work.
We'll see, but we're going to
do a little bit of that later.
OK.
So what is Cloud Speech API, and
why are we so excited about it?
So it's our neural network
based speech recognition.
I already mentioned before--
we're making it available
for the first time now.
And it's universally available
across 80-plus languages
and variants.
Basically, I think more
than half of the people
that use smartphones
today around the world
are already covered, and we're
aiming for more than that.
You can use it in
two different modes--
real time streaming and batch.
And I'm going to show you a
little bit of both later today,
and it's accurate in
noisy environments
and with different accents.
So when we built our
speech recognition,
we needed it to work for
people that are walking around
in Times Square, walking
around with their phones,
and asking their phone,
what's the weather like in New
York, while there's 100 other
people right next to them.
And so it knows how to
filter background voices.
But there's also people in India
that are walking the street,
and there's a bus passing
right next to them.
And so it knows how to
filter all different kinds
of background noises and
focus on the primary speaker.
And the last thing here
I wanted to emphasize--
we have a really easy
way of customizing speech
to your domain.
So if you have a name of a
company or a name of a product
that's not actually a word
in English or in the language
that you're trying to work
in, we make it really easy.
All you need to do is just
tell us what that word is,
and we automatically add it
to the dictionary for you,
and we can start recognizing it.
If you're in a specific
mode in your application
where you're expecting a certain
command-- so if you're building
speech recognition for a player,
and you're playing a movie,
so you might want to
detect stop and pause.
But then when you're
not playing a movie,
you might want to detect
play or other words.
You can use word
and phrase hints
to detect exactly the words
you need in the right context.
So we have three different
methods for using Speech API--
streaming, sync, and async.
Streaming allows you to
process speech in real time
while the user is saying
it, and so it's the fastest
way of using Speech API.
It works with
something called gRPC,
which is our improved
binary version of REST.
The gRPC people are going
to kill me for saying that,
but it's a faster, more
efficient protocol and way
of sort of accessing
remote procedures,
and it allows you to
process any audio,
up to a minute, that's included
inline in the requests.
Sync is a much
easier-to-use method.
You can use it on REST API.
You can even do it
with a cURL command,
and it can process any
audio, up to a minute.
You can either embed
the audio inline
or use Google Cloud Storage.
And then we have
async, which allows
you to process larger files.
It's basically not limited.
It says up to 80
minutes, but that
can be increased if you
get a quota increase.
And it can also be
accessed by REST
and can process
files either inline
or at Google Cloud Storage.
So with async, because
it's not blocking,
you can quickly process
a large number of files
and then just check back in to
see if they're done processing.
In terms of standards, when I
wrote this slide I was even--
I forgot how many different
standards we support.
It's pretty universal.
That's something
we're very proud of.
There's a large list of
programming languages
you can use to
access Cloud Speech
API and a large list of audio
encodings that we support.
Now, this is not an experimental
project that someone at Google
is running.
This is a commercial
service that we're fully
backing and really developing,
investing a lot in.
So I wanted to give you
guys just a little bit
of best practices.
If you are developing
speech recognition apps,
what would we recommend?
And our first slide is about
human-computer interaction,
so the left-hand
side of the use cases
that we spoke about earlier.
So for human-computer
interaction,
you really want to use
streaming whenever you can.
When you can't use
streaming, you can use sync.
But then there's
going to be a delay,
and users are waiting
for a response,
so it's not recommended.
You always want to use
uncompressed audio if you can.
And if you want to
compress, you should
use lossless compression,
because lossy compression,
like mp3s or things
like that, they really
degrade the accuracy
of the recognition.
Ideally, you want to use as high
of a sampling rate as you can,
but at least above 16 kilohertz,
or 16 kilohertz or more.
You don't want to
go below that if you
want to use human-computer
interaction,
if you have a choice, if you're
not running on phone lines.
And whenever you can, you
want to use speech context
to get the best-accuracy
results that you can.
Now, using Speech API
requires that you specify
the language in advance.
So what we see a lot
of app developers do
is they detect the
language of the OS.
And that way they
know what language
the user is going to speak,
and they provide that
to Cloud Speech API.
So then there's the
other set of use cases,
which are speech analytics.
So there you're
typically dealing
with longer-form
audio-- like, a call
could be 5 minutes, 10
minutes, 15 minutes.
A movie could be one hour,
two hours, three hours.
So you want to use
async, most probably.
You want to store those
files on Google Cloud Storage
and then process them in batch.
And if there's
multiple speakers,
you may want to separate the
streams so that you can process
the speakers separately.
If you're processing
a video, you
might want to use a tool like
FFmpeg to strip out the audio
and just send the audio
to Cloud Speech API.
And it's very easy to combine
it with Natural Language API
and Translation
API, which you're
going to see in a second.
OK.
I wanted to give you
guys a few examples
of human-computer
interaction, because we're
going to spend more time
later about speech analytics.
So Azar is a video-chat
discovery app.
Does anyone here in this
room know about Azar?
OK, a few-- so apparently
they have 15 billion discovery
matches already.
So what they do is they
connect people with new people
that they don't
know, and they've
done it 15 billion
times already.
Yeah, every time I hear
about this, I'm just shocked.
And most of the
time or many times,
it's people in
different countries
that speak different languages.
And there's a little bit
of a language barrier,
like you can imagine, when two
people from different countries
want to talk to each other.
So what they do is they use
Cloud Speech API to transcribe
the speech into
text, and then they
use Translation API to
convert that from one language
to another, and they allow two
people in different countries
to talk to each other.
And as they're talking,
they see on the screen
what the other person is saying,
and they can react to that.
So it's pretty cool.
It's really sort of enabling
use cases that were not really
possible even one
or two years ago--
very, very exciting.
Another example is Tribe,
which is a messaging
app that uses video.
And it allows people that
don't want to type a message--
they just want to say
something to their friends.
They can record a quick video,
say whatever they want to say,
and Tribe will show
the video [AUDIO OUT]
enable adding text to that
video by transcribing the text
and defining some
sort of keywords,
or alerts, or things like that.
So if you mention a dinner,
or a restaurant, or something,
it can react to that
and give the user
more information about what
they're talking about--
pretty cool.
OK.
So now I want to show
you guys a few demos.
Can we switch to
the demo computer?
Yeah.
Cool.
So this is always risky.
Speech recognition demos
in a large room with echo
is not what it was intended for.
But what I'm going
to show you now--
I'm just using a
regular computer,
and I'm using the mic from the
computer-- from my computer--
nothing special, no
special equipment.
I'm just going to talk
close to the computer,
and let's see what
it's able to do.
I think it got 100%.
I'm not sure.
Usually it gets
100% or close to it.
It doesn't always get
every single word,
but I think this
time it might have.
And I don't know if
you guys noticed,
but while I was
talking, you could
see on the top the words
were appearing in real time
almost in the exact same
moment that I said the word.
So it's pretty impressive.
It's very, very fast.
The other thing I would
say is interesting
here is you can see that I
said the word meet twice.
And even though I pronounced
it in exactly the same way,
it knows how to differentiate.
And from the context
of the sentence,
it knows when I said
you know this meet
and when I said that meat.
So every time this
works, I'm always amazed.
It's pretty cool.
Let me show you something else.
I really love Taylor Swift,
which is true, by the way.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
We have a bug in the demo here.
But you can see this demo uses
a couple different elements.
So one is it combines Speech
API with Natural Language API.
So you can see the overall
sentiment is positive,
so it detected that.
And it also extracted
the entity, Taylor Swift.
And it brought up a card.
It knows it's a
singer-songwriter.
It has a little bit of a
description from Wikipedia,
and you can click on the link.
But the other thing
I wanted to show
you is our speech recognition
was built originally
for our search engine.
And so it's built to recognize
named entities really,
really well.
We get searches for every
single entity you could imagine,
and a lot of those searches
are voice searches.
And so we developed our
speech recognition in a way
that it knows how
to handle that.
And when you mention
entities with speech,
we will detect them, even if
it's not a word in English,
and we will format them.
So you can see it's
capitalized, and it knows
how to recognize the entity.
So the third and last demo--
so this is a demo
that sort of tries
to teach you how to speak a
new language with Speech API
and with Translation API.
So it's going to detect
that I'm in an airport
and about to fly to Tokyo.
And it's going to try
and teach me Japanese.
COMPUTER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
DAN AHARON: Did
you guys hear that?
COMPUTER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
DAN AHARON: OK.
It wants me to say [JAPANESE].
So I'll try and get this wrong,
and let's see what happens.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
OK, that wasn't wrong enough.
Let me--
COMPUTER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
DAN AHARON: Let me try this one.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
So apparently, what I said in
Japanese is, "King [JAPANESE]
soccer."
So it actually recognized
my language in Japanese
and then translated
it back into English--
so pretty cool.
OK.
So these are pre-prepared demos.
And you'll say, OK, that's
fine, but how easy is it really
to use?
So what I'm going
to show you guys--
if you just go to Cloud
Google account slash speech.
You click on View Documentation,
and you click on our samples.
You can see samples
for all the languages
that I mentioned earlier.
I'm going to go to
the Python sample.
And you can see
there's basically
a Python example here.
And I've loaded it
onto my computer,
and I prerecorded
this audio file.
I'll play it for you guys.
RECORDED VOICE: I'm really
loving this session so far.
It's pretty awesome.
I especially like all
the code examples.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN AHARON: So hopefully that's
representative of some of you.
If not, then maybe
a little bit later.
And let's try and--
I pre-downloaded this demo.
Let's try-- can you
guys see my terminal?
Maybe make it bigger?
Is it better now?
OK.
I'm going to try
and transcribe it,
and let's see what's happening.
So it's taking this file that
I recorded in a library called
code, and it's sending
it to the cloud
and getting a result back.
So you can see, "I'm really
loving the session so far.
It's pretty awesome.
I especially like all
the code examples."
So it kind of got
the gist of it.
But now what happens--
let's say we wanted to add
sentiment analysis to that.
How do we do that?
So I'm going to go to our
natural language page.
And if you just click
How To Analyze Sentiment
and go to Python, there's
a code segment here.
I'm just going to copy
it and add it here
to our Python script.
And I can just put
this up front here,
and let's also import
from Google.cloud--
import language.
And let me fix the indentation,
and now we want to feed it
this text,
alternative.transcript,
which is what comes back
from the Speech API.
So let's feed that here.
And then we do the
sentiment analysis,
and then let's print the score.
I don't think we
need the magnitude,
so we can just hide that.
Let me save.
Let's run it, and let's
see if it actually works.
So this is--
OK.
So it worked, it
got the transcript,
and it got the sentiment score.
So what do you guys
think about that?
That was pretty easy.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
So let's make it
more complicated now,
and let's also add translation.
And let's go back to my editor,
and let's paste it in here.
I'll put the client
up front, and I'll
import the library from
Google.cloud, import,
translate.
And let's add this here.
And now let's feed
it-- instead of text,
let's give it this
alternative.transcript.
And instead of target
language, let's just
give it ES for Spanish.
And now we don't
really need the text,
because we already printed it.
Let's print the translation.
OK.
Now let's run it.
Let's see what happens
now when we run it
with the combination of--
so what it should be doing now
is showing us the transcript,
then showing the score, and
then showing the translation.
So that's it.
We have it.
It worked in Spanish and
with the sentiment analysis.
Let's try one more thing.
So I wasn't sure if you
guys would really like this,
so I also recorded
a different option.
Let's play it.
RECORDED VOICE: I really
hate this session so far.
It's very boring.
I can't wait until it's over.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN AHARON: OK.
So let's try and transcribe
that with speech recognition
and also analyze sentiment
and translate that.
And let's see if
that's going to work.
So that's it.
It worked.
[APPLAUSE]
So it's pretty awesome, and
this is our beta version.
As I mentioned, we're going to
have our GA version coming out
soon, and it's going
to be even better.
Yeah.
I can't go into
too much details,
but we're very excited about it.
So with that let me
welcome onto the stage Gary
from InteractiveTel.
[APPLAUSE]
GARY GRAVES: Thank you, Dan.
If we can go back to
the slides, please?
InteractiveTel provides services
that capture and analyze
business communications.
A lot of the data we collect
is audio from the recording
of phone calls.
We have clients that accumulate
a quarter of a million minutes
in one month of conversations.
To put that in
perspective, it would
take one person 173 days
of continuous listening
to review every call.
Now, normally those
recordings would just
sit there until
something happened
that caused a
particular conversation
to come under scrutiny.
When that conversation
went under scrutiny,
it may be because of a
disgruntled customer or even
a lawsuit.
Services like the ones that
I'll show you today transfer
information from a phone
call to CRM companies,
to lead and contact management
systems, and even to managers,
in the form of a text message
when something goes wrong.
We're able to provide this
value by translating speech
into text using Cloud
Speech API and provide value
to our clients.
Since the new services
we've been able to provide,
we've been able to add 75
new accounts in 30 days
and over 2,100 new opportunities
just from these new services.
Let's talk a little bit about
the architecture that we use.
From our telephony
infrastructure,
we stream speech in real time
to Google's Cloud Speech API.
We take the results
we got from Google
and then pass them through our
analysis engine, which extracts
sentiment, keywords, and
key phrases, all of which
are used to construct an
understanding of what's
happening on a call.
We take our findings
and then publish
them to CRM companies,
R data visualization
tools, and other subscribers.
They take that information
and then pass it along
to managers, who can
intervene if necessary
and analyze the data to
see what's happening.
If we could go to
the laptop now?
I'm going to share with you a
video of exactly what happens
in a dealership when this
technology is in use.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Thank you for
calling ABC Motors.
This is Jack.
How may I help you?
- Hi, I'm calling about a car I
saw advertised on your website.
It's the 2017 blue sedan that
was signed by John Davis.
- Yes.
We've received several
calls on that car.
It's really one of a kind.
Let me take down your number.
In case we get disconnected,
I can call you back.
- I don't mean to
be rude, but I don't
want to give out my number.
I'm just interested in the car.
Can you tell me if
it's still available?
- Let me go put my
hands on in to be sure.
Please hold.
[END PLAYBACK]
GARY: I also came up
with a nice demonstration
for you guys, which is going
to require some participation
on your part.
So our specialty is business
communications, capturing
and analysis.
So we thought it would be
pretty cool for this demo
to have members of the audience
call a number, which represents
the telephony portion, and we
tie into Google Cloud Speech
API.
We'll ask you where you're from.
You mention your country,
city, state, or what have you,
and we'll plot that on the map.
So the number that's
on the screen--
201-300-4800.
For any willing
participant out there,
if you pick up your cell
phone, make that call,
you'll be prompted to
say where you're from.
And hopefully we'll get
enough participation
that we'll start getting some
blips up there on the map.
So if you will, please
make some calls.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
That's pretty cool.
So this is using gRPC
to stream in real time
while you guys are on the phone.
And you'll notice a lot of
names are popping up there.
We're doing reverse phone
append to also attach
additional value.
What's also interesting
about this particular mash-up
is if you don't say
a city or state,
and you say a
particular company,
if that company has a presence
on Google Maps, that would also
show a dot there.
We'll leave this up probably
for the rest of the day.
So if anybody was savvy enough
to copy the URL, the phone
number, this demo will be active
for the remainder of the day.
I'm going to transition
into the code
behind this particular demo.
It's very similar to
what Dan showed earlier.
Effectively, this is
the telephony code
where we're playing greetings,
recording the file locally.
And the transcribe file function
is very similar to the one
that Dan showed earlier.
Of course, we've enabled
the profanity filter
to make the results
less interesting.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
If we can go back to
the slides, please.
We did have some
technical challenges
when implementing Cloud
Speech API, the first of which
was time stamps.
And I don't know
if any of you here
are a part of the user
groups, but that's
a topic that came
up quite frequently.
Many phone calls are 15
minutes or longer in length,
and an important part
of our user experience
is allowing a person to
click on a keyword or phrase
and skip ahead to a
phone conversation,
to the point at which that
word or phrase was spoken.
Currently, Cloud Speech API
does not provide time stamps.
But we did devise a
way to implement them
that works for us.
The way we did this
is as follows--
we pre-process the
audio to detect silence
in between words and phrases.
We then use that detected
silence to segment the file
and submit those segments
individually to Cloud API.
The responses we get
back we associate
with the segment in the
interval at which we detected.
And it allows us to know that,
for instance, Segment A, which
comprised the first 8/10
of the conversation,
was the word Google.
We repeat that process
for each word and phrase
in the recording,
and it enables us
to construct a transcription
of exactly what happened
on the call and the time
in which it occurred.
Another issue we ran into
was speaker diarization.
As we're a telephony
company, we have
two sides of the conversation.
Cloud Speech wasn't really
designed, initially,
for this type of conversation.
So we record our
files in stereo,
which gives us a
caller on one channel
and the callee on the other.
Now, if we were to
take that audio file
and separate them
into two channels,
we'd end up with
one minute of audio,
one minute of a phone call,
and two minutes of audio-- one
minute for the left side,
one minute for the right,
effectively doubling our cost
for processing a stereo file.
In order to mitigate
that we expanded
our pre-processing algorithm to
detect large spans of silence.
We then remove that
silence from the audio
and submit the
segments individually,
keeping track of
whether that was
submitted for the left
side or the right side
of the conversation.
We then reconstruct the
transcription, using the method
that I showed you earlier,
associating segments
with time intervals, but
also associating them
with the caller or callee.
Our experience with Cloud Speech
API has been pretty awesome.
I learned a term yesterday,
which is dark data.
And for us, recordings-- and
for probably a lot of you
that may have audio that happens
today in recording format,
it's just dark data.
You don't know what's
going on there.
Well, using Cloud
Speech API, we were
able to shed light
on our recordings,
and I'd like to thank you
for allowing me to share
that experience with you.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN AHARON: Maybe if you
can stay on stage, Gary,
I actually have a
question for you.
GARY GRAVES: Sure.
DAN AHARON: So could you
talk a little bit about--
so once you transcribe
these phone calls--
like, for example,
that scenario that you
showed in the video,
where a customer is
calling about a car
that's not in stock.
What do you guys do in
terms of the analytics,
in terms of the workflow?
How do you provide value
to car dealerships?
GARY GRAVES: That's
a great question.
So an example is you see a car
on a website, and you call in.
And for whatever reason,
that car is not available.
This particular dealership
is using our system,
so we know exactly what's
happening on the call.
In the automotive space, they
have a notion of everybody
that calls in, you want to get
their contact information--
their name, their number,
product of interest.
So that if that product
does become available,
because it's a
very fluid market,
you'd have a point of contact
to reach back out to them.
So we identify a
couple of key factors.
Number one, the
call was for sales.
Number two, there was a product
that they were interested in.
And number three, there
was no contact information
that was collected.
In our space we call that
a missed opportunity, which
becomes actionable
because we'll send that
to a sales manager in the
form of a text message
and/or an email,
based on his settings,
to let him know that this
particular opportunity may
have been missed.
What ends up happening
in those cases--
large dealerships have this
instance occurring dozens
of times a week, and it really
impacts their bottom line
to be able to have a
second chance at selling
that particular customer.
DAN AHARON: So what have been
reactions for dealerships
that have tried the new system?
GARY GRAVES: Well,
the reaction has
been overwhelmingly positive.
In fact, large dealer
groups that we've demoed
and had an opportunity to show
our system to end up pushing it
throughout their whole group.
I don't know if I'm allowed
to mention customer names or--
DAN AHARON: If
you could just say
in terms of business value--
are they actually
making more sales,
or is this just a nice-to-have?
GARY GRAVES: Well, not only
are they making more sales,
but it's causing a shift in the
mentality at car dealerships,
because now everyone
in the dealership
is being held accountable.
It's one thing to have a
recording or monitoring
solution in place, and
people know it's there.
But that's reactive,
meaning the only time
that that information
is ever going
to be leveraged is if there's
a situation that calls that
into question.
Whereas using Cloud
Speech we're able to mine
these conversations for
actionable intelligence
to allow us to empower dealers
to be proactive and provide
a higher level of
customer service.
And it's really becoming
disruptive in our industry.
DAN AHARON: Great, awesome.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
You can stay here.
I just have two more slides,
and then we can do Q&A.
So I just want to give you guys
a plug for two more sessions
that are happening a little
bit after this one in about 30,
40 minutes.
One is Sensitive
Data Management.
So you get all this text
coming back from Speech API.
A lot of it is going
to contain PII.
A lot of customers have asked
us, what can we do about that?
So if you saw the keynote today,
they spoke about a new product
that we just announced this
morning called Data Loss
Prevention.
We're going to talk more about
that product in this session,
room 3020 at 5:20.
And then for those
of you that are
interested in building
conversational applications
and connecting to
Google Assistant,
there's a lot of overlap
there with speech recognition.
There's a session that's
going to dive deep
into that right in this
room, actually, at 5:20.
So those are the two
upcoming sessions.
With that, let's go to Q&A.
[MUSIC PLAYING]